the perfect pairing cookies and beer the
pink boots society las vegas chapter and
troop 83 girl scouts
are putting together a cool event that
incorporates both in honor of women's
history month they are bringing together
women entrepreneurs and craft beer
cookies and cans it's a two-hour live
stream event ladies from four nevada
breweries will be showcased
viewers will also learn how to pair and
taste certain beers and cookies together
organizers say this will be a fun
educational event that will also promote
entrepreneurship
and support troop 83. it's been a
wonderful opportunity getting to know
some of the girls in the troop and
really just encouraging them on their
journey and becoming young entrepreneurs
and you know
saying hey this is an organization we've
developed a business relationship with
them
we've introduced them to some of the
other businesses downtown
again the event will be online it runs
tomorrow from 2pm to 4pm
you can buy your kid online we have a
link on our website 8newsnow.com